tonight
we've had the pleasure of seeing
performances of this year's best
original songs once again here are the
nominees
Claws from tell it like a woman music
and lyric by Diane Warren hold my hand
from Top Gun Maverick music and lyric by
Lady Gaga and blood pump lift me up from
Black Panther wakanda forever music by
Thames Rihanna Ryan coogler and Ludwig
bornson lyric by Thames and Ryan coogler
not to not to from rrr music by mm
kirvani lyric by Chandra Bose this is a
life from everything everywhere all at
once music by Ryan Lott David Byrne and
mitsky lyric by Ryan Lott and David
Brown
all right are you guys ready
gender Bose originally earned a degree
for electrical and electronics
engineering before becoming a Lyricist
composer mm piravani list John Williams
is one of his musical influences
foreign
I grew up listening to The Carpenters
and now here I am with the Oscars
there was only one wish on my mind
so was rajamaulis and my families
[Applause]
to win
pride of every Indian
[Music]
and must put me on the top of the world
thank you
and variance films for making this
possible
love you all thank you namaste